I had some kind of a shamanic experience
where I felt that my mind was being
crystallized along different lines
what is a shaman and why do you say a
shaman is one of the most original of
all artists ah yes well Shaman is uh
it's a word that has grown Way Beyond
its Origins it was originally used
by uh
so-called native people
in Siberia regions and now it's been
expanded to mean any kind of Wise Old
healer of the tribe anybody who takes
charge of magical
operations within the tribe who blesses
things
sometimes they curse things or people
but they are the holders of the esoteric
knowledge the knowledge of the unknown
or the other Spirit worlds
and
they are known for
traveling to these other worlds by
various means they have access to them
in a way that Ordinary People don't
and usually they have arrived at this
condition
through some catastrophic event in their
lives it's very common that people will
discover that they are meant for this
Shaman creative role
because of some catastrophe in their
life
many of the old ones in the the tribes
used to write about or tell about
being attacked by a bear or something
like that and really mauled up and
chewed and almost at death's door but
that process of being chewed up broken a
lot of Bones broken and so forth allowed
them to reassemble in a different way
and it's almost like they became
radio receivers or Crystal sets that
could receive the Transmissions of this
other world and many uh
anthropologists have collected stories
about these people who also say that
they have a certain particular kind of
dream that guides them to be uh a shaman
or a Healer of the tribe they call them
uh in anthropology they call them the
wounded healers because often they do go
through some kind of near-death
experience
either in reality or in their dreams
and so these are the original artists I
think I I think that these things happen
spontaneously a long long time ago
but that we can see evidence of it uh in
the cave paintings that have survived
for 40 000 years in some cases
you see images of people dressed up in
the skins of animals
dancing and obviously doing some kind of
magical operations
in the disguise of animals and that's
part of their deal is that often they
will form a relationship
with a particular animal that's
important to the tribe maybe that you
know they live on the deer or they live
on the Buffalo and so somebody needs to
be the mediator between the Buffalo and
the human beings and you know understand
if the Buffalo all have gone away where
did they go and what can we do to bring
them back so the shamans sometimes have
that
function that job to do to bridge the
gap or if there's something wrong in the
society like all the water has dried up
the the streams aren't running anymore
the shamans sometimes will put a rug
over his or her head and just meditate
for a while and travel to these other
worlds to the spirit world and they're
the spirits tell them well you have to
go up to the source somebody has to go
up to the spring and see what's gone
wrong up there and then they March up
there and they find that well trees have
fallen in and the the way for the water
is blocked so we have to on we have to
clean the drains and we have to open uh
the the water so that it can flow again
or we have to do something to make peace
with the animal world or with the spirit
world nature world and the shamans often
will bring
uh that message in a form that we
recognize as creativity dances songs
stories images they'll make images of
gods and goddesses uh masks that allow
people to get a little taste of this
other world or they'll bring back from
the spirit world they'll bring back a
dance and have everybody do the dance
and it has the effect of bringing people
together and healing whatever was out of
balance so they're they're the natural
balancing agents that bring the Two
Worlds into a happy harmonious
relationship at least that's the ideal
so then current artists are we are we
broken individuals trying to make
ourselves whole
through our art I think every artist
recognizes a little bit of this shamanic
uh heritage
because
you don't get to be an artist by being
happy and by being uh
unconcerned about things or having no
problems to deal with in life you would
be a pretty boring artist if you came
from that background and that approach
it doesn't mean that you have to suffer
to be an artist
but you have to understand and have
experienced
some of the darker side of life so that
you can interpret it and deal with it
convincingly to other people
so I think it's it's part of the kind of
common idea about artists is that they
they suffer and if they haven't suffered
enough they're not going to be a very
good artist so there is some truth to it
although I wouldn't say go out and make
yourself miserable if you want to be an
artist it'll you don't have to worry
about that it'll come to you you know so
don't go seeking for trouble
but yeah I think this shamanic thing is
it's something that came up for me
uh when the pandemic hit
uh I didn't know what to do as a kind of
artist or somebody who kind of ministers
in a way to artists
um and then I thought well then the
thing to do is the shamanic thing which
is to go inward
and so I went for a series of long walks
alone and uh tried to
open myself to okay Universe you've
thrown us this gigantic curve how are we
supposed to respond to it and uh
if there are such Spirits I think they
speak to us when we ask them and I asked
and the answer that I got in my mind uh
was go Inward and all artists should
really go to work now to make Works to
interpret this and to help people and
heal people because the world needs it
very badly
so that's my my orientation to the
shamanic uh obligation is when things
are out of balance that's the artist and
the Shaman's job to give people
metaphors in the form of songs dances
stories uh art that allows people to
compare their own situation to that of
the characters in the song The Dance the
story The Art and
take lessons from that
in a kind of safe way you know where you
you aren't experiencing it yourself but
you're seeing pretty drastic things go
on and uh if you're smart you'll take
lessons from that
sure that's interesting that you said uh
experience it yourself because it almost
sounds like a a method actor in some
ways where the dark side of that is then
you can take on
the dark energy or the sadness
of others
in trying to help
yeah you know I think there are dangers
and warnings
to be observed here you know that you
you are dealing with very very intense
forces uh within yourself
and that just exists around us
and as an artist you open yourself up to
that
but you also are obligated I think to
maintain a very strong sense of yourself
because it would be easy to get lost
and to uh
find yourself tempted by the power that
is offered by these things
I I'll just say this that in the early
development of my ideas I had a kind of
a shamanic experience where I had worked
very hard on a paper for class just a
term paper about Star Wars and close
encounters and this Joseph Campbell
Heroes Journey idea and put it all
together and stayed up a couple of
nights doing all-nighters as students
will do and I was in an exhausted state
of mind after turning in the paper the
next day and something hit me I had some
kind of a shamanic experience where I
felt that my mind was being
crystallized along different lines and
and where I might have seen things like
a cube before simple you know
six sides and a few angles all of a
sudden it was uh some complex geometric
shape like a dodecahedron that has 12
faces and uh is very complex with lots
of interactions
so uh
in in that process I felt I was
communicating with
the spirit world
and this is all in my head I'm not like
seeing visions or anything I'm just
thinking
and it was as if there was a crowd of
nurses or doctors around me who were
saying ah there's a live one here's a
guy who's kind of tuned into this stuff
and uh
we can offer him a deal here
that you can use this material this idea
of the hero's journey any way you want
you can start a new religion you could
run the world you could do all sorts of
things create a very successful business
out of it if you want Market it
or use it benevolently to heal the world
you know it's up to you and I thought
for just a second and I said well if we
have the choice let's make the world a
little bit better place let's use this
to tune things up make it better and
those Spirits in my mind said good
choice and we will support you in that
and So you you're gonna have to work
hard don't get the wrong idea but we
will look out for you and if you keep
the positive view of this forward and
you make it with that intention that
this is for good then we'll support you
and and all will be well so and that's
really been borne out in in my career I
certainly had that to work hard but I've
always felt backed up by that original
choice and by those
Spirit guides so I I take the shamanic
thing pretty seriously as a real thing
for me